nouvelle émission à partir du 16
décembre face à Baba
Cyril Hanouna
[Musique]
le premier invité sera Éric Zemmour
en direct juste après cette émission
avec
deux ou trois le concept de l'émission
et on va revenir ma sœur surtout ce qu'a
dit Éric Zemmour ce sera notre premier
invité donc il sera face à moi et phase
2 ou 3 éditorialiste avec moi et
pourquoi Éric Zemmour en premier et de
venir depuis très longtemps dans
l'émission voilà et on a lancé cette
nouvelle émission on se dit pourquoi pas
lui en premier puisque apparemment il a
des grosses annonce à faire en décembre
notamment le 5 décembre rendez-vous
français donc on va voir ce qu'il va
annoncer mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit le
16 décembre le jeudi soir s'arrête un
événement alors il y a plein de gens qui
me disent oui je t'avais dit que je
recevrai jamais avec ces mots je l'avais
dit oui c'était il y a 2 ans aujourd'hui
apparemment il va se présenter aux
élections présidentielles donc forcément
envie de faire tous les pour voir ce
qu'il est capable de dire qu'il est
capable de faire et c'est vrai que là ça
reste un exercice un petit peu
particulier pour lui c'est pas le sortir
un petit peu de ce qu'il fait
habituellement et je suis très content
en tout cas faire cette nouvelle
émission juste
parce que on parle également d'une
émission politique est-ce que c'est la
même que ce sont deux c'est une nouvelle
émission
2022 qui va s'appeler c'est déjà à vous
de voter avec 200 personnes du public
des petits boîtiers
ce sera sous forme de sondage on aura
les candidats à la présidentielle
on attend tout le monde est face à Baba
Baba exactement demain j'adorerais
faire une émission avec Kilian voilà
[Musique]
et
voilà voilà
voilà
bonjour c'est bientôt Noël et
voilà si vous avez des questions
Place d'Arc
[Rires]
ça fait du bien de vous voir en intimité
aussi avec les gens
de quoi
zone de confort c'est ça et pour c'est
déjà à vous de voter vous aurez tous les
candidats officiels déclaré qu'ils
viendront
maintenant je vous dis parce qu'on a pas
encore